mesdames et messieurs ça n'est pas mon
anniversaire je vous invite donc à
revenir au moins deux fois plus nombreux
le 17 août prochain pour me le fais tu
es quand même si on avait pu faire une
chose pareille
renault que de penser un seul instant
qu'on ferait un meeting le jour de son
anniversaire c'est pas si je serais venu
mais je suis très content d'être à tes
côtés
on fait en effet un très bon boulot
ensemble avec laurent au sein du conseil
des régions de france
nous défendons mesdames et messieurs une
cause difficile
martine et jean claude lessard qui est
celle de faire en sorte les libertés
locales puissent être affirmée dans
notre pays pour qu'on puisse
différencier les politiques bâtir des
politiques énergiques adaptée au
territoire
ce discours là pendant plus de deux ans
le gouvernement ne l'a pas compris ne
l'a pas entendu et ce matin matignon
chacun buvait du petit lait si on
pouvait considérer que les choses
n'étaient pas grave quand le
gouvernement nous demande désormais mon
cher renault observeront de procéder à
nouveau à de la régulation publique sur
l'apprentissage
après nous avoir expliqué il ya plus
d'un an que les régions étaient
incapables de développer l'apprentissage
voudrais aussi vous dire une bonne
nouvelle sur toi laurent je ferai dans
les 20 minutes
une bonne nouvelle à l'heure où je vous
parle il ya un meeting à caen où nous
étions avec françoise aviez et laurent
il ya toujours 10 jours et ce meeting
la salle était pleine et nous étions
entre 800 et 1000 personnes et je vous
assure que c'est pas les chiffres de la
police contre les chiffres des syndicats
il y avait vraiment mille personnes et
bien ce soir en marche a fait venir sa
grande figure le premier ministre
l'ancien maire du havre avec des membres
du gouvernement nombreux qui sont
normands le ministre en charge des
collectivités
le ministre en charge de l'économie vous
savez ce qui faisait des meetings avec
vous il ya encore deux ans y avait il ya
aussi l'ancien ministre l'agriculture et
bien mesdames et messieurs ils ont été
obligés de mettre rideaux occultants et
ils sont deux fois moins nombreux que
vous ce soir ça fait assez plaisir
françoise aviez alors mes chers amis
deux mots simplement le premier pour
vous dire pourquoi je suis là
j'aime marseille oui on le sait je suis
souvent venu faire des meetings à
marseille mais je suis là pour deux
raisons la première mesdames et
messieurs quand avec laurent on a évoqué
la question des européennes j'ai même
pas discuter ya même pas imaginer
ensemble à soir ça a duré moins d'une
heure parce qu'on était cuit l'un et
l'autre
quid fatigue je rassure et le rang me
dis qu'est ce tu comptes serge dugas
écoute pour moi il n'ya même pas de
débat on sera ensemble au moment des
européennes et on sera ensemble pour une
raison simple mesdames et messieurs si
celle qui a évoqué renault et martin
tout à l'heure c'est extrêmement simple
nous sommes ensemble dans les mairies
nous sommes ensemble dans les
départements nous semble ensemble dans
les régions je ne me voyais pas tout
d'un coup pris d'une espèce de
schizophrénie ahurissante qui m'amenait
à considérer que j'irais faire campagne
contre ceux avec lesquels je suis pour
bâtir un nouveau projet politique
notamment quand je parle de liberté
locale et donc dès lors qu'on est
ensemble dans les communes de l'eure
qu'on est ensemble dans les départements
et dès lors qu'on est ensemble dans les
régions ils conspirent à l'être encore
l'année prochaine et l'année d'après
eh bien on est ensemble aussi au moment
des européennes c'est ce qu'on appelle
de la cohérence
et puis il ya un deuxième sujet mesdames
et messieurs que je voulais évoquer avec
vous c'est que mesdames et messieurs dit
le bien à nos compatriotes qui
aujourd'hui s'interrogent vais-je aller
voter pour qui il va voter
dix corps bien une chose simple
emmanuel macron n'a qu'un seul schéma en
tête mesdames et messieurs nous laisser
dans un choix qui serait lui ou le chaos
le chaos qu'il a lui même su générer
depuis six mois
en clair c'est moi où le front national
est bien mesdames et messieurs moi
j'aspire que nous soyons en mesure
républicain et centristes à bâtir une
alternative en 2022 est la première
brique pour bâtir cette alternative
elle commence maintenant avec les
européennes et les élections du 26 mai
les français on te le droit d'avoir un
autre au choix que celui de se dire que
si c'est pas macron s'offre à marine le
pen bien moi je dis si c'est pas macron
on doit être capable mais chers amis
dans les deux prochaines années à dire
aux français il ya une solution
alternative
c'est ce qui d'une part vous dise la
situation réelle du pays et qui deux ont
le courage de vous proposer un certain
nombre de solutions qui sont des
solutions permettant au pays de se
redresser
vous avez vu le formidable formidable
numéro d'équilibriste du chef de l'état
et huit jours au moment de la conférence
de presse et le taxi qui m'emmenait à
l'ayraultport me dit à la fin de guerre
sur moi vous en pensez quoi la situation
politique du pays via le savez quand
même
mâcon c'est une sacrée déception dit
c'est moi tous mes clients disent c'est
quand même un sacré comédien
eh bien oui en vérité sur chaque sujet
il les aborde sans réellement les
aborder ou en racontant à nos
compatriotes des histoires qui sont pas
réellement d'une histoire si on les
regarde au fond je prends simplement
d'où trois sujets le premier nommé
messieurs il a annoncé une retraite
minimum pour tout le monde à 1000 euros
je me suis dit ça au moins c'est une
mesure que nous portions d'ailleurs
pendant l'élection présidentielle
ça c'est une mesure que j'approuve
sauf que ce que vous n'aviez pas perçu
que c'est une retraite de 1000 euros
pour ceux qui ont une carrière complète
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui aller 2 953
euros et que l'effort il est que de 47
euros pour nos compatriotes c'est à dire
qu'on n'est pas tout à fait sans schéma
qui avait été évoqué après un deuxième
sujet la question du rééquilibrage de
notre régime de retraite
alors je suis pas pour travailler plus
dans la semaine dit il je suis pas pour
travailler plus longtemps
je suis toujours pour l'âge de 70 ans
mais rassurez-vous l'âge pivot restera à
62 ans mais comme au bout du compte on
l'a tous compris y aura une décote
il faudra quand même travailler plus
longtemps mais sans n'ose pas vous le
dire et puis prenons un dernier sujet
mesdames et messieurs prenons celui de
la création d'emplois quand il annonce
les créations d'emplois depuis qu'il est
président de la république qui c'est
assez formidable
il redevient hollandais mesdames et
messieurs puisque quand il annonça cent
mille emplois créés il prend les 360
milles qui ont été créés durant l'année
2010 est c'est à dire à la fin du
quinquennat françois hollande est donc
sur chaque sujet il raconte
mesdames et messieurs une fable avec
beaucoup de talent se reconnaît et bien
sûr la construction européenne mesdames
et messieurs c'est la même chose
renault l'a évoqué sur chaque sujet
il évoque à travers ces deux discours
celui de la sorbonne puis celui
d'athènes une perception une
construction de l'europe que personne ne
partage en europe à même aujourd'hui nos
amis allemands et donc ils racontent aux
français une histoire comme la comme
françoise aviez et laurent vous le
diront une histoire qui ne peut être
écrite avec personne puisque sa
refondation de l'europe n'est pas celle
que souhaitent les autres européens et
je vais prendre pour cela mesdames et
messieurs deux seuls exemples pour ne
pas être trop long le premier il évoque
la question de l'harmonisation fiscale
et de l'harmonisation sociale
l'harmonisation fiscale mesdames et
messieurs type quoi un seul instant
qu'on peut nous français se présenter
devant les européens en parlant
d'harmonisation fiscale
quand nous sommes mesdames et messieurs
le pays d'europe où le déficit
budgétaire le plus élevé de tous les
pays européens les italiens font
beaucoup mieux que nous lorsqu'on est en
capacité d'afficher 25 à 30 milliards
d'euros de déficit supplémentaire à
travers les annonces de ces derniers
jours et quand les allemands se retourne
et vous disent mais l'harmonisation
fiscale qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
vous souhaitez simplement que le niveau
de nos prélèvements obligatoires
deviennent ceux de la france dont on
sait à quel point c'est un succès pour
l'économie pour les entreprises
mesdames et messieurs il ya sept points
d'écart de prélèvements obligatoires
entre la france et l'allemagne
vous croyez qu'un seul pays européen qui
a envie de matraquer ses compatriotes
comme nous on les matraques aujourd'hui
bien entendu personne et donc
l'harmonisation fiscale c'est une fable
quand on évoque avec les européens
parce que les européens nous disent une
seule chose fait l'effort vous-même
d'abord fait l'effort pour revenir au
même étiage que
nous sommes l'harmonisation sociale
mesdames et messieurs la directive sur
les travailleurs détachés extraordinaire
la travel direct entre lyon détaché
un flan incroyable la presse qui dans
les premiers mois nous expliquer que ça
y est il y aurait plus de concurrence
déloyale n'y aurait pas les travailleurs
détachés ces mêmes paronnaud la question
de la concurrence déloyale le pire c'est
d'accepter que des hommes et des femmes
en europe travaillent 70 heures par
semaine dans une camionnette et ont des
conditions de travail que nous
n'accepterions jamais pour nos
compatriotes
c'est ça le scandale du travailleurs
détachés et bien sur cette question la
fameuse directive modifiée c'est celle
qui passe le temps du travailleurs
détachés mesdames et messieurs de 24
mois à 18 mois
quand on sait qu'en moyenne à
travailleurs détachés et là quatre mois
dans l'année
et quand on dit à travail égal salaire
égal mais c'était déjà le cas mesdames
et messieurs la seule question qui se
pose est c'est celle des cotisations
sociales sauf que les cotisations
sociales c'est toujours celle du pays
d'origine et donc en vérité on n'a pas
remise en cause
la question de la concurrence déloyale
tel qu'on l'a si souvent évoqué dans nos
réunions politiques donc deux sujets sur
l'harmonisation fiscale et sociale et
derrière en vérité du vent deuxième
sujet mesdames et messieurs je parle
devant quelqu'un qui connaît aussi bien
que moi ces questions qu arnaud danjean
les questions de défense mesdames et
messieurs puis simplement mesdames et
messieurs dénoncé la posture que
représente le message du chef de l'état
il ya quelques semaines sur l'armée
européenne
mesdames et messieurs l'armée européenne
ça fait plaisir ça sonne bien et
d'ailleurs si les français sont très
favorables à l'armée européenne c'est
peut-être pas forcément dans le concept
c'est parce qu'ils disent que ça nous
coûterait peut-être moins cher parce
qu'on
faudrait des coûts je pense qu'il ya
presque plus de cela arnaud que le
concept lui-même mais admettons que ce
soit le concept mais mesdames et
messieurs je vous pose cette question
est ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya un pays
européen qui est prêt à bâtir une armée
européenne pas un pays européen ne fait
aujourd'hui un effort significatif sur
sa défense tous les pays européens ont
renoncé à assurer leur sécurité c'est un
drame pour l'europe
nous sommes encore la deuxième puissance
économique du monde la première
puissance commerciale et nous avons
renoncé à nous défendre par nous-mêmes
et faisons confiance à l'alliance
atlantique pour le faire alliance
atlantique qui de plus en plus tourner
le dos à l'océan atlantique
mais il n'empêche il n'y a pas un pays
européen qui a cette volonté d'assurer
par nous mêmes notre sécurité notre
défense
mesdames et messieurs ça existe les
structures européennes
le record l'état major de force à
strasbourg 800 800 900 hommes qui sont
formés et entraînés pour faire un état
major de force
est ce que vous les avez déjà vu en
opération oui quand ils ont été en
opération ils ont été sous commandement
de l'alliance atlantique
c'était en afghanistan et mesdames et
messieurs quand nous intervenons au mali
est ce que pour lutter contre le jihad
nos partenaires européens sont à nos
côtés pour éviter le chaos sur cette
partie de l'afrique non ya pas de
volonté il existe des structures
il existe qu'on appelle les battle group
les forces de réaction rapide c'est 15
cents hommes qui sont préparés pour
intervenir
jamais les conditions dont était
considéré comme retenu pour faire en
sorte qu'on mette en place cette force
de réaction rapide européenne et vous
voudriez mesdames et messieurs qu'on est
une armée européenne dont je vous
demande simplement de savoir qui en
serait le chef
tel qu'une petite question comment
seraient employés les hommes dans
quelles conditions vous imaginé cette
histoire
et puis mesdames et messieurs je suis
européen comme vous n'imaginez pas et
pourtant mesdames et messieurs il ya
bien un sujet sur lequel je renonce ou
je refuse plutôt pardon je refuse à
l'idée de confier ma propre sécurité aux
européens c'est bien avec nos 27
partenaires ou no 26 partenaires
mesdames et messieurs quand il s'agit
notre propre sécurité notre propre
défense cela dépend de la nation
française et c'est au sein de la france
que se décide notre sécurité notre
défense et notre souveraineté comme pas
confier à des pays qui ont renoncé à se
défendre et assurer leur sécurité
ma propre sécurité quand en plus ils ne
font pas d'efforts
premier sujet deuxième sujet un mot
rapide mesdames et messieurs dénoncé
auprès de vos amis ce qui parfois sont
tentés par le discours du rassemblement
national
quand marine les poèmes marine le pen
évoque le fait que si tout va mal
ce serait la faute de l'europe ni
mesdames et messieurs si tant de choses
vont mal en france c'est pas la faute de
l'europe
c'est notre faute c'est notre
responsabilité à nous collectif a new
nations and au peuple français en vous
brillez d'érable ou politiques mais à
nous tous étaient quand même ce que vous
ayez ceux qui sont élus c'est vous qui
les avez luc françois hollande c'est pas
les autres qui l'ont choisi bien et bien
mesdames et messieurs
quand vous voyez l'état de notre justice
est ce que c'est
la faute de l'europe est-ce que lorsque
vous voyez nos résultats scolaires et
nos classements internationaux
quand vous voyez l'état de nos
universités est ce que c'est la faute de
l'europe
est-ce que mesdames et messieurs canton
on voit la difficulté que nous avons à
mettre en place des systèmes de
formation pour les demandeurs d'emploi
tant les mécanismes sont complets est ce
que c'est la faute de l'europe
et bien vous pouvez prendre l'essentiel
des mots qui sont les mots de notre pays
l'europe n'en est absolument pas
responsables et mesdames et messieurs
pensé que nous pourrions nous priver
l'europe
quand on voit que le monde et la planète
est en train de basculer du côté de
l'asie
quand on sait que dans les dix
prochaines années
plus aucun pays européen ne sera dans le
classement des dix premières puissances
mondiales
quand on connaît les défis liés à la
question migratoire est au réchauffement
climatique qui peut penser qu'on peut se
passer de l'europe
la seule chose c'est que on ne peut pas
penser l'europe telle que nous la
présente le chef de l'état ou ne la
présente
marine le pen il faut une autre europe
refonder rebâtir l'europe refonder
l'europe c'est à dire bâtir une europe
où en clair on considère que les nations
sont l'une des articulations dans la
construction du projet politique
européen
et c'est ce projet là que
françois-xavier défend avec toute sa
liste
alors mesdames et messieurs pour
conclure mon seul espoir
il est simple c'est que au soir du 26
mai mesdames et messieurs nous puissions
dire tout simplement
oui l'europe est de retour l'europe est
de retour différemment et oui mesdames
et messieurs la droite et le centre sont
de retour je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]